over the last few days I've been trying
out and playing around with the year 5
pts one of the first things I was Keen
to jump into was the new game mode
descent so in this video I'm going to
run through how the mode works and
provide some of my thoughts around it at
the end
firstly I have to say it so I'll say it
right now this is a pts what we are
seeing here has the potential to change
not the entire thing or anything so this
still gives a good idea of what to
expect but there are some obvious areas
that are being tested out and will
likely be adjusted for the final release
with that in mind let's check it out
on my first run I jumped in with my mate
alpha bravo we were taking our sweet
time plotting through the rooms and I
was making sure to check everything out
to make sure I wasn't missing anything I
had some pretty rough RNG with a fairly
subpass starting skill and rifle however
I quickly found out that grenades and
ammo are quite important because you can
so clearly see where the enemies are
coming from you can just throw a grenade
and that would usually just clear the
spawn allowing you to focus on the other
door
so I quickly stacked into extra grenades
and although I would have preferred an
assault rifle of some type I found the
rifle to be far more economical on ammo
which became more important in the later
rounds
I'm not going to say it was particularly
difficult especially when you're given
the option of hard medium or easy rooms
to choose from but to be fair it was our
first run and we were just mucking
around to try and figure things out
eventually we came across the Nemesis
encounter there was a pretty cool
simulation animation where the music
obviously hadn't been added for the pts
but we got the idea that was about
to go down
I'm not sure what I expected but given
how the last 20 rooms or so went it
certainly wasn't this
like the cocky beasts that I am in these
games I ran forward and was completely
bum rushed by one of the two Nemesis
characters it almost took me out in one
shot to be fair it may as well have
because I was lying on the ground
shortly after with alpha bravo falling
not far behind me
we ended up calling a knight after that
but I was left thinking I don't really
understand this game mode like I don't
get it what's the end game what are we
fighting towards
so first thing in the morning I decided
to take another crack at it on my own I
actually did a couple of runs in the
morning because I wanted to see what
would happen if I took the choice to
leave early rather than being killed so
I ran a few rooms and made it past the
first boss room and left
I honestly couldn't see anything gained
through doing this but maybe this will
change it seems to be a bit odd to
include the auction when instead I could
just let myself die or quit
with the Knicks run to my surprise my
RNG was even worse than before a
terrible skill and a choice of weapons I
really didn't want
but at least I knew what to expect this
time I leaned on my grenades and I was
fortunate enough to gain the mad bomber
Talent which refunds grenades if you get
a kill with them but I knew this
wouldn't be useful for long as the
enemies would get tougher
eventually I would get a combination of
weapons that I wanted a decent rate of
fire assault rifle and a high damage
rifle after the first run as a doer I
had a bit of a strategy I would put
everything into armor and focus on
maxing out the offensive talents with
just a couple of the stronger defensive
talents like adrenaline rush and
preservation
my skill was rubbish so ignore these
talents for the most part this would
allow me a steady stream of armor with
more than enough DPS going out
once I reached the Nemesis I felt in a
much better position or at least I
didn't think I'd be down in one shot to
play it safe I also purchased shock
rounds for both my rifle and the assault
rifle
the plan was to be aggressive and stop
them from getting too close while
attempting to predict the incoming shots
I loaded it up and Unleashed it was
actually really easy the assault rifles
scared the Nemesis back and with the
rifle and shock rounds it basically
Stood Still while they took it down I
tried this a few more times later on and
I definitely recommend it if you're
having trouble with the Nemesis round
anywhere from here I continued through
the rounds managing to stack talents I
was running two and even three times on
some of them the enemies were getting
tougher and more numerous but my build
was also getting much stronger I was
barely using midkits and my ammo was
maxed out
I was creeping up on three hours played
and I think I was sitting at around
level 11 or 12. I felt like I could have
gone for at least another 10 levels
based on how things were playing out but
real life got in the way and it decided
to dip out the next opportunity
before I continue with my thoughts
around the game mode it needs to be
stated that the rewards haven't been
included in the pts at this stage and
these could have a massive impact on how
I personally feel about it
this could be the best way to acquire
resources towards expertise or gear
optimization or maybe it'll be the most
efficient way to gain XP
because right now I can't really see
that my time spent will be rewarded in a
way that will be worth me playing this
game mode any more than once or twice
so what did I think about it well
starting with the environment it felt
very underground but with a division 2
twist like in the division ones
underground each area felt like more of
an arena you can see across the map and
in descent you can even see where
they're coming from before they spawn
you are given 10 seconds to get prepared
before anything attacks this felt a
little bit cheesy to start with but when
you get to the later levels you're
certainly more thankful for it I can't
complain about what the environment has
shown me so far but there was certainly
a number of Boss encounters that played
out on the exact same map and while this
made things much easier to prepare for
it did get a little bit repetitive
there is a chance of a hazard in each
encounter this could be electricity like
we've seen in countdown where you have
to get off the ground before you get
shocked but there could also be
hazardous clouds that you need to stay
away from or even explosive gases
these are an absolute pain in the ass as
soon as you can upgrade to reduce the
chance for hazards as minimal as they
may seem they make a huge difference
where things start getting tight
as I said earlier there are options
between rooms to choose from as far as
the difficulty level goes I like this
this is good provided there is an
advantage to taking up these higher
difficulty levels because right now I
don't really see any reason to take on
the more challenging rooms a few more
credits but that's kind of about it
otherwise as a whole I wouldn't say the
difficulty was overly too challenging
once you learn the mechanics and you
choose your talents wisely I feel you
only get stronger like I said only
played in bursts of one to three hours
at a time so I'm not sure how things
ramp up in the later levels
I really enjoy the mechanics around the
weapon skill and talent distribution yes
it's completely RNG but I enjoy being
forced to use weapons and skills that I
wouldn't usually pick in the main game
the talent system is a particular
favorite of mine the number of weird
pieces you can throw together makes for
some pretty strong builds especially
since you can stack them adrenaline rush
and preservation stack three plus times
are felt unkillable
and then there are the Exotic talents
some of these are awesome I wasn't very
lucky with the ones I was seeing they
didn't really complement the builds I
was making but I could certainly see how
these could change things up
the only thing I was confused about was
the skills I would get one at the
beginning and that was it I never saw
another option to get another I'm not
sure if it was something I was doing
wrong but this basically led me to
ignoring skills altogether
baby new skills only come up every 20
levels or so but by that point unless
you've been speaking into them the
skills are pretty worthless this could
be a bug or maybe something I'm doing
wrong I guess we'll find out soon
I play these types of games for the
evolving story and the feeling of
progression
the more time I put into it the more my
character grows
while I really enjoy some of the
mechanics that have gone into descent I
don't really think I'm the target
audience for it
don't get me wrong I've thoroughly
enjoyed playing through it multiple
times and I'm planning to play some more
of it as of writing this to make sure I
haven't missed anything
but I don't think I'll be able to play
this any more than once or twice after
it releases
to jump into this mode and play it for
three four ten hours I can't see what
they'll be able to do to reward me for
the time spent towards the main game to
make it worth it for me
this mode actually feels like more of a
variation of a horde mode to me I know I
could keep playing and reach greater
levels Etc but why would I bother how
does this benefit my character in the
main game
I've been very open on my thoughts
around previous game modes like survival
and Last Stand and I love these but I
can be done with each of them in well
under an hour so the rewards game don't
really matter so much
if I'm playing something like descent
let's imagine I played for 24 hours
straight and I managed to get to a level
of something ridiculous like I don't
know 100. I'm not really going to be
Keen to jump into this again knowing
that I'll have to spend at least another
24 hours straight getting there again
maybe I'm not the target audience for
this game mode and we have no idea what
the rewards will be like but as it
currently stands and yes this is a pts
so things will change I don't believe
descent has a place in this game at
least not one that makes sense to me
Summit wasn't the most amazing game mode
out there and it had challenges and
things that would reward certain Exotics
Etc but at least you could walk away
from it continue later on
so while I love some of the mechanics I
rate descent as having lower interest or
lasting power than even the summit at
this point
but these are just my thoughts have you
tried out the pts maybe watch some
streams what do you think of it I
welcome a challenge to my opinion around
this like I said maybe it's just not my
thing but exactly what the rest of the
community is after
leave some comments in the description
this is a pts the divs need all the
feedback we can give
anyway thank you very much for watching
this and I'll catch you in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]